[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
insane in the end game
i am national master caleb denby filling
in for a grand master in residence
tonight uh and it's a very special topic
uh so as i was talking to the in-person
audience here a lot of people know uh
cappa blanca as the great end game
maestro
but uh tonight i want to talk about uh
one of his predecessors uh not by long
but i guess technically a predecessor
akiba rubenstein who was very talented
in rook and games so the story goes
uh so to start off tonight i want to go
over a game between spielman and
rubenstein that happened back in 1909
and this is potentially one of the more
famous rook end games in existence
i believe the story goes that after the
game
spielman told rubenstein that uh if he
were alive in the middle ages he would
be burned at the stake because what he
does in rook end games can only be
called witchcraft now
misquoting a little bit a little bit of
paraphrasing but uh let's see how
magical rubenstein actually is
so of course this is an endgame class i
don't care about any of the chess game
that happens until we get to this end
game
okay so
still don't care still don't care and
i'm gonna wait for the bishops to be
traded
and
okay i sort of spoiled uh my first
question already but that's okay here we
are in this rook end game
so part of what i want to talk about
tonight
is the balance between good calculation
and what we call endgame knowledge or
principles you know the the theoretical
stuff
that you're just supposed to know
um because i think a lot of people
assume
that the end game
is all about knowledge you know whoever
knows the most principles whoever uh has
the most knowledge about the end game is
is going to be better
but my argument has always been that end
games are first and foremost kind of
like all chess about calculating with so
few pieces on the board you can
calculate to pretty great depths you can
see really far into the position see
what's going on and whoever calculates
better uh can make better decisions so
we're gonna see how that plays into uh
into the end game we have here but my
first question for you guys is white has
just played rook 1 to c2
in taking stock of the position we see
that black has just two pawn islands two
whites four
and that plays into endgame knowledge a
little bit it's better to have your
pawns grouped together because they're
able to defend each other you know you
see the f pawn defends the g pawn the f
pawn was weak we could move it and it'd
be defended by the g pawn
whereas white's pawns are all all by
their lonesome unable to defend each
other and so theoretically black might
be a little bit better in the end game
because these pawns are going to be a
little bit weaker
uh but our first decision is what to do
in this position white just played rook
1 c2 defending against the threat of
rook f2 and we are faced with a big
decision we could play rook takes c2 uh
trading down we could take the free pawn
on a3
or we could play something else i don't
know maybe like rook b2 rook a1 and
those are all the moves that don't hang
a rook so
my question to you guys is which of
these moves seems the most appealing to
you and why let's talk about it
and hello to everyone in the twitch chat
or not twitch we're on youtube tonight
and one in the youtube chat
can never get enough rook end games i
agree
so any thoughts
trade so why trade over uh maybe the
more natural taking the taking the pawn
on a3
uh
what i said about what about the
position of your
just phone you have the advantage right
now
um
yeah kind of kind of
uh there's something more more direct
that i want to talk about
then
you know i mean trading down is is fine
for black we're still gonna be better
because of our pawn structure
but i mean keeping pieces on the board
should still be fine as well like
there's no reason why
trading down would increase that
advantage
yeah so that's closer closer to the
truth um
but the big thing i wanted to point out
is it's it's all about calculating you
know those principles are useful you
know having an active rook on the
seventh is something we want to get rid
of that's a good principle you know
rooks on the seventh are powerful
but at the end it comes down to chess
moves um and so the reason why i don't
like rick takes c3 is because of very
direct very concrete moves for white
here so there's actually a direct
uh idea that i want to avoid uh as black
here
yeah brian
um
and then
other rook to c7 yeah that's exactly
right um so rook d7 pressures the d6
pawn if you play a slower move like rook
b6 you're gonna get met with uh
rook c to c7 and you can defend your f
pawn over here but okay actually hold on
i just blundered mate in one um not so
good you were defending the ball yeah i
did defend the pawn that's that's a good
point um so that goes to show you know
black already has pretty serious
problems but let's say we play a
slightly better move like uh
i i don't know it's hard to suggest many
moves here something like like rook f3
first of all this pawn is already
falling second of all uh king g2 and
these ideas are still going to be in the
position
uh and so this is why i'd rather take on
c2 than play rook takes a3 because rick
takes a3 white has very direct ideas
that give black concrete problems
and that's the point i was trying to
make earlier you know following
principles like activating the king you
know keeping your opponents pieces
passive they can lead you to the right
moves but that's not the end of the
story you have to calculate you have to
say well you know what is the problem
with taking an extra pawn and once you
find stuff like grip d7 then you see
okay so rick takes a3 these moves are
the reason why uh i don't want to go for
that so we get rick takes c2 in the game
and that's the best move
now rook takes c2
and
black's next move is actually very very
important
so i'm going to take a moment here and
look at some of the options so
uh
i think someone in the audience
mentioned bringing the king out so
that's one option what are some other
candidate
moves or ideas here
yeah so activating the rook um rook b3
was uh your specific idea let me get rid
of some of those arrows
uh with the idea of of course attacking
the a pawn it and cutting the king off
on the third rank
any other ideas
um
i mean possibly
a8 and then to
a4 to
yeah so
these are our three big ideas i think uh
bringing the king in king e7 uh or
activating her rook somehow and our two
big ideas for that were either rook b3
or rook to a8
so how do we decide between the these
ideas um
and i'll give you a hint it's about
calculation
so you want to calculate a little bit
here that that's what end games are
about yes you know we we know the
principles that's how we got our
candidate moves we want to activate our
rook and activate our king but the
question is you know what's what's the
best way to play and you find that
through calculation so
for example what's black's response
or what's white's response to rick b3
what's white's response to rook a8 and
what is white doing against king e7 as
well and if we analyze those a little
bit further that's how we arrive at the
truth the truth of the matter
so i think we can eliminate one of these
moves uh without too much controversy
here
so which one of these seems like the
least likely to to be
yeah so why why is the king move maybe
not ideal
yeah it's going to allow white to get
active right away we're gonna get this
rook back here on the seventh um
and it's gonna be pressuring the pawns
can also activate a rook like this
support our a pawn pressure along the
seventh rank and
i have a hard time believing that uh
white is going to be in too too much
danger here um there's another idea that
white can play against king e7 as well
but that will
maybe lead us to uh to why the other
move is also not as good so king e7
gives white too many options to be
active we want
to force our opponent
uh into passivity we want to make his
pieces passive and uh defending while we
can activate
um
so i'm gonna say
that uh that that's not gonna be the
reason uh to pick rick8 over rook b3 if
that is
uh what you want to do
because
okay i mean for example if rook b3 rook
8 check
oh sorry rook c8 checking rook a8
i i think white is pretty immediately
uh losing some pawns here like uh the d4
pawn is weak
if you try to defend it like this i can
activate my king
and
uh i think you're just losing the d-pawn
so yeah rook c it is is not going to be
the problem with with any of our lines
uh so there's a very famous rule in rook
end games
it's a very famous rule and it has to do
with past pawns
so where do rooks belong with with past
pawns
yeah rooks rooks belong behind past
pawns and that's going to be the reason
why one of these moves is better than
the other i also wanted to point this
out in the event of king e7 as well it
might seem like a move like rook a2 is a
little beside the point uh you know
we're activating our king we're coming
into the center why why rook a2
but even here i think this is going to
give black some problems if if black is
still trying to win the game i mean this
pawn is coming up the board
we have to blockade it eventually
and then while black uh is coming over
to capture this guy
uh we might find ourselves
uh uh unable to get a winning position
here you know if we defend this i come
back
push i'm invading
and you can never really take this pawn
without losing d6
and then this end game should be a draw
we have two pawns against three even
though our pawns are split black has a
lot of trouble uh winning this game
should just be a technical draw
so it's a very important idea for white
to be able to go rook a2 and push the a
pawn down the board because it's going
to distract the black pieces over even
in the event that we pick up the d-pawn
it might not be enough to win the game
so with that information in mind
with this very clear plan for white uh
which of these moves is going to be
better rook b3 or k8
yeah so why is this better
um against something like route k2
hey bryan
that's exactly right now we have better
than going king e7 and trying to win in
the center we can go rook a4
and stop this pawn all the way back here
on eight three uh and with this pawn on
a3 obviously uh
white's gonna have a tougher time
distracting our pieces away you know
we're gonna be able to maybe take the d
pawn and start to
start pushing ourselves
so rook a8 is much much better than rook
b3 it's against rook b3 again rook a2 is
going to be a big problem
you can maybe go like rook d3 try to win
this pawn
but again
you're just going to be way too slow in
the long run you can block hate you're
not losing by any means
but uh i mean even like rook a6 here we
activate the king and we're gonna get
that drawn end game
uh okay so first big decision here rook
a8 uh is a very very important move now
in the game spielman chooses not to go
rook a2 and instead plays the move rook
c3 trying to defend from the side
uh and now rook a4 still this is a great
move uh pressuring both pawns and
forcing this rook to be uh even more
passive than than before
and now finally once we've uh forced
this rook to be passive uh what's what's
the next step
for black
yeah just king e7 bring the king into
the game uh we get king g3 by white
king e6 uh king f3
and i'm going to cheat a little bit okay
one more move king d5 puts pressure on
the the d pawn
whites steps back with king to e2
now again end games are all about
calculation uh so both players had to
decide what's happening after rook takes
d4
and what's happening is i think this
should just be a draw
a4
and i don't think this is what black
wants to be going for i do think the
evaluation is a draw but if anything
it's going to be black who's in trouble
here
with these pawns
everybody loves a good old-fashioned
pawn race
um
so once again calculation very important
um showing that ratix d4 is not going to
be enough to win for black
so uh we have achieved two of our our
big goals we activated our king we
activated our rook we've kept the white
rook passive back here
on d3
so
having achieved all that uh what else
can black do here to try and continue
putting the pressure on
uh the kingside pawns
okay so
how do you wanna how do you wanna do
that what's what's our long-term plan
aside from
you know in in specific moves
what are we going for
oh you want to go to f5
and then like long term
like what are you hoping to to do like
what's what's your destination for this
f pawn
actually to get
one of the
pawns on the
file
pass yeah so okay
trying to make uh trying to make a past
pawn um
the issue here is i'm not so sure you
can even do that like let's say i pass
forever
like what is how do you make a past pawn
here
yeah
g5 you get g4 i take it
and
still no past pawns the f pawn still uh
still blockades
so it's not quite that simple for black
you can't really make a past pawn with
this three versus two on the king's side
um you could but then if you're king uh
leaves sort of this attacking position
um
well actually maybe you just can't
because like where does your king go if
your king's in front of the pawns you
might get checked around
and uh i think our king is well placed
in the center of the board you know
maybe someday it'll come to the king's
side but maybe it'll also come to the
queen's side so it's it's nice and
flexible here
well that's that's the thing i'm not
saying it's not a pawn move but uh our
idea is not so much to try to make a
past pawn on the king's side but we can
actually improve our structure here a
little bit yeah brian well
i was wondering about
g5 followed by f5 just to control all
the all those squares yeah so g5 is is
actually the the great move that
rubenstein starts with here
and this move is really important it
keeps both of these pawns sort of at bay
uh and it grabs a little bit of extra
space for
black
on top of that you know black might not
actually want to play this move f5 it's
a little bit weakening it's going to
make it a little bit harder to keep
track of all the pawns
but simply f6 and black's pawns on the
king's side are going to be very very
solid and we'll see why that's so so
important in a little bit um but for now
g5 is a great start it keeps these pawns
at bay it grabs a little bit of extra
space on the king's side
and it's going to make it easier to
target these weaknesses right because
you know in this position if you imagine
somehow the h pawn gets attacked maybe
it moves up to h4
um and you have to to chase it down a
little bit a little bit further
um in fact g5 is so powerful that white
should probably play a different move
here um white should probably actually
be playing h4
um you want to keep uh the g pawns at
bay as white just as as black one
just as black wants to keep your h and f
pawns um where they are so something
like h4 would stop these pawns in their
tracks and make it a little bit harder
for black to get a nice solid structure
so in the game king e2 maybe maybe a
mistake by white we get g5 by rubenstein
rook b3
uh and this move is uh again trying to
escape from being so passive white is
okay in a lot of positions with parting
uh with this
uh d-pawn as long as he can get active
something like roof b7 even giving up
this pawn
and going for for end games like this i
think this one should just be a draw as
well
if i'm not mistaken
don't think i'm mistaken
okay um not to mention you know in in
the in this event you would have to
calculate this as well but i think rook
b7 is good enough here
and same thing with something like this
something like rook b7 and then against
rook f4 i think white has
an important resource here
any ideas
what was that
yeah i was thinking this move a4 and the
point now is that we want to take this
pawn with the rook but now again we're
going to be able to come over and uh
start taking your pawns on the king's
side
uh
what are we talking about
oh root d3 okay that's that's maybe the
simplest um and we get the same end game
that we were looking at earlier
although
yeah if anything this is a better
version for white which might mean black
is in trouble but
probably not with all these pawns
um okay so so rook b3 and yeah rook d3
is the simplest so we get f6 again we're
just solidifying our structure over here
on the king's side
now king to e3
uh again i don't think black wants to be
playing something like f5 f5 is really
only serving to make both of these pawns
weaker than with this pawn on f6 uh so
with that in mind we've kind of improved
our king to the maximum it's great on d5
uh it seems like our rook is very well
positioned as well again rick takes d4
is met with rook d3
um
so what do we do now seems like we ran
out of improving moves
so what's the plan
what's the plan now
it's not so easy
this board game
i'm gonna cheat to make sure i know
where we are because
okay
i do know where we are
sometimes these end games they shuffle
around it's easy to lose track
um yeah so
we've kind of
successfully avoided that by having our
rook on a4 uh for example i mean rook b7
was playable last turn
but you don't really want to give up uh
these these pawns in particular i think
um although okay i should probably no i
do want to take this one instead
if you attack my guy i'm able to defend
it
and i think this endgame should be
winning um if anything i'm putting my
rook on f4 and taking your d-pawn and
two pawns to the good is good enough
so we have prevented rook b7 for the
moment
we need some way to improve our position
further
all right the youtube chat wants to try
and put white into some kind of zugzwang
but they're not sure how
somebody suggested rick a5 but i mean in
this position i i can just repeat
something like rick c3
with the idea of rook b3
with the idea of rook c3
very strong
i did not
so what's the story king c4
why does it seem good
okay it comes with tempo so white plays
rook d3
what's uh what are we
achieving
okay d5 and let's say white continues to
pass king d2
do we do we have a plan for improvement
maybe
it's a little ambitious to play uh the
full ring around the rosie but no you
guys are right this does improve our
position uh and the reason why
is because number one our pawn is sort
of one step closer to being relevant one
step closer to queening number two we're
also taking away a lot of squares from
this rook uh we're no longer really
worried about these lines um so someone
in the audience correctly pointed out
this is nice because the rook is never
really coming active anymore
um and we're also taking away just all
these squares so white just might find
himself
short on moves pretty soon here um
so
we do have a really nice active plan in
this position
and then i have a funny story as well
so someone in the chat asks won't our
king get harassed on the c4 square and
the answer is is pretty much just no um
you can't ever really attack this king
without losing your d-pawn
i mean give it
yeah i love it so now that our king is
so actively placed on c4
um
up to this point our rook has been
serving a really really important
purpose on the a4 square it's been
stopping white's past a apon from
advancing any further and having any
chance of being relevant
um but as you may know
rooks are more powerful pieces than
kings so we would much rather have our
king
serving this purpose
of stopping the a pawn then our rook
because the rook's more mobile has a
better shot at attacking white's pawns
and so this kind of changing of the
guard is is very important and that's
another reason why king c4 is is so good
it frees up our rook to come over here
with rook a8 and now moves like a4 are
not really um okay well i'm sorry
let's say king c2
i play like this move or something
a4 is still not going to be super
important because our king can quite
easily stop this pawn
um
so rook a8 played in the game and this
is a very good way to put on some
pressure uh to white's position
now white plays the move king to c2
and my funny story is is approaching
here
so chat room i'm going to lead you down
the the red herring
uh in the game rubenstein came up with a
very very creative idea almost too
creative uh to put white into zugsvang
and for years
annotators of chess games were praising
rubenstein for this move exclamation
points everywhere so good putting white
into zouzovong
but i have something they didn't have
which is
uh
you know something like a 3600 level
player in my corner 3 500. i don't know
what stockfish is rated these days but
it's pretty good
um
purely because you said that it has an
exclamation point i'm just gonna guess
g6
oh no g6 doesn't get an exclamation
point so we don't want to touch these
pawns um right now our pawns are solid
and g6 again just just makes more
weaknesses if rook ever lands on the
sixth rank he's able to tackle the
points
well you're not wrong
you're not wrong but you know rubenstein
considered it obviously
so i'll just go ahead and tell you
well i won't tell you but i'll show you
what the uh sort of the line of thinking
at least what i think the line of
thinking was so
everybody wants to play rook e8 looks
good right we're activating the rook uh
it's better than rook h8
because rick kj doesn't really come with
a threat so we're activating the rook
we're threatening rook e2 trying to pick
up the f pawn we're also threatening
rook e4 trying to pick up
um
the d-pawn
so now what i think the the idea was
here is white plays king d2
rookie four
and then white plays
a4 and is is able to sort of uh distract
uh the the black king away directly
so somebody got the bright idea to say
ah but if it were white to move in this
position then perhaps white would not
have any useful moves and black could
get something similar with the rook
still you know back here out in front of
the pawns so we could you know maybe
force something like
um
let's just say it was white smooth i'm
gonna triangulate very clumsily white to
move here
uh and you know let's say maybe white
has to play some losing move like a4
then we can just come right back in
front of the pawn and and pick it up for
free without committing to rookie 4 or
anything
now i think that was the line of
thinking
which is why
in this position rubenstein was aiming
to get this rookie 8 position with the
king on d2 now how does he achieve that
just plays rook a7
and all the annotators lose their minds
rook a7 what a concept passing the move
back to white and now after king d2 we
get rook e7 uh achieving our goal
uh but the problem here is that white is
able to play a
a move
that is perhaps more useful than
rubenstein or the annotators bargained
for
so white to move here and spielman
actually finds it in the game
and the youtube chat is asking some very
important questions
um which is
again
who calculated rookie three like we're
skipping over a lot of all the difficult
calculations
but uh rookie three it's what end games
are about
whoever can calculate it correctly
so i'll be impressed if you guys come up
with this move
yeah best move for white here and it's
actually uh i don't know if it's the
only move that keeps him in the game but
uh
certainly a very very important idea
all right and just to satisfy the chats
let's look at what happens on rookie
three
of course black thought of this move and
would play rook takes e3
uh and it turns out this end game is
going to be good for
black
if we take with the pawn
um now i didn't prep this endgame
specifically so i'm you know i'm going
on the fly here so if you see something
wrong tell me but i think f5 is going to
be quite good f5 stops any idea of e4
making a past pawn
and if we try to come over here
we can just go f4
take take
take and these pawns actually defend
each other due to king and pawn trickery
for example here
and white cannot capture the pawn
otherwise the other pawn will queen
so king and pawn end game looks good for
black if we take with the king
this king and pawn end game also looks
good for black
there's there's not too much going on
here i think
i guess you have to calculate a little
bit
but i think
this is going to be simple enough any
ideas like this are just way way way too
slow
not a chance
not a chance so rookie 3 is no good
doesn't get the job done
and that's why it's important to
calculate
all right any ideas doesn't matter if
you don't have the details worked out
but
okay f3
uh f3 is is not gonna be it uh i think
in this instance
now we can actually switch our ideas and
start going after the h pawn that's not
so good to to block off the rook's
access to that guy
um
yeah and here i think you just have too
many problems
so to highlight the other important line
to calculate king c2 seems to be the
only passing move that white that white
has this is why um you know the
annotators thought rubenstein was such a
genius because white doesn't have a good
move that passes if you play king c2 of
course we're gonna go rookie two
and again after much calculation you see
that this kingpin end game is also
winning for black so king c2 doesn't get
the job done
that means white can no longer pass can
no longer hold his little fortress here
which is why the zugzwang at first was
thought to be such a great idea
and the chat room has a good idea rook
c3 check so the time is finally right uh
for white to just give up this d-pawn
and start going for active play
uh so rick c3 check was was played in
the game and now all of a sudden
we're getting a four we're able to
activate our our queen slide pawn
finally i'm going to put the rook behind
it
and give white something to think or
give black something to think about on
the side of the board roxy through check
was needed by the way because you play
a4 right away
my king is here in time to uh
to catch the pawn oh i'm sorry rook a7
as well this was the idea that i uh that
i mentioned
um
versus in this position i have player k7
play rook a3 and it's going to be a lot
different
um okay so rick see through shrek is the
big idea which is why
my bold claim here i'm going against
decades of thinking in the chess world
um
and so much so that like i tried to do
some research see if anybody annotated
this game recently uh to point out this
move but i think rookie yet is just
winning and we'll see that's in the line
played in the game uh maybe black is is
no longer winning so rookie 8 and what's
the point well the point is now we are
threatening rook e2 so white is not in
zug's wong but does have to respond to
this this makes king 2 d2 the only move
if you try to do something similar
with uh czech and a4
uh now it's just not gonna work out for
you i get rookie two i get to take your
pawns
and you're you're in a lot of trouble
here doesn't matter if the e pawn is
rolling because i'm up so many pawns on
the king's side
um so you have to go king d2
and now rook e4 is just very very direct
uh you have to try for this a4 plan
still
um by the way this is still not good for
black
so we go king before as planned
but the problem now
is that at the end of the day
we have some ideas and
i computer checked all of this i don't
want to get too bogged down in the
details
but at the end of the day we're going to
end up with something like this
okay
something like this just trust me all
the lines end up in some version of this
this is about as good as i can make it
for white
and here
black has a winning idea
so i want to see if you guys
know your theory know your end game
theory here
so
what is black aiming for in this
position
to make it winning
well yeah i've if only it were so simple
right now both of white's pawns are well
defended
so i guess that's the question we're
going after this guy are we going after
this guy
what can we do
okay we could push g4 but
what's uh
what's going on in that position
okay
so g4 is a very very important idea it's
almost the right idea but we can do a
slightly improved version of it
uh not quite so
uh
here i want to remove some of the
mystery here let me tell you the
position we're aiming for
so if the g pawn and the h pawn
disappear from the board everything else
is as it is
two connected past pawns are always
going to be winning against the one
passed pawn on a5
so that's the the theoretical knowledge
that i was digging for
now if you just like know that then
that's great because now you can
calculate and figure out how you can
force that position so black can force
that position here
yeah it's exactly right rook h4 king f2
trying to come defend
and now g4 yeah we get takes takes
and
to prove it table base
says
black is winning says this is a losing
position for white
um i don't know if you guys have ever
used table bases before but that this is
what this is what it looks like
um when it's uh a win
the little block here is colored black
so
uh that's why i think that this rookie
eight move is just winning the game and
again
you know if you see my notation here i
got pretty in depth with uh analyzing
this position
but this is sort of the main variation
here uh that's uh that black has to keep
track of
and by the way why is g4 not good
well i i think it's this move h4 i'm
going to cheat though because no it's
okay so h4 is still no good because we
can go g6 and we still get connected
past pawns
but
uh the move rook g3 is going to be good
enough and after g takes h3 we can take
the g pawn rather than the h pawn and
now my my friend over here says that the
game is a draw
uh so rook g3 is is the critical move
that that we're looking out for again we
don't really care about this guy
the story is all about what's happening
over here on the king's side
um so that's why i think you know
annotators throughout the decades were
all wrong rook a7 it's a nice idea
trying to put white into zugsvang here
but uh in the end sometimes it's better
just to play with the tempe
um by the way there's one more critical
line i want to show here a4 is really
the only idea for white to try to escape
but now after rook d4 rook d3 f4 king e3
um
rook f5 rook d4 check king c5 again this
is all more or less the only main
variation here
now in
the previous line i showed i played rook
d3 for white the idea is to help keep
everything defended and i played this d4
tactic for black to
overwork this white king between the two
rooks
but white could also theoretically try
rook to d1 here and now after d4 play
king e2
and white might be holding in this
position
but black has an improvement with rook
f4 and now the problem is
black can go after basically all of the
remaining pawns for example rook c1
uh king d6 rook a1 rook h4 and now with
the h pawn falling we're going to end up
with something very very similar
we're at the end of the day
uh well here for example rook takes a
seven and uh it's gonna be
winning i think
i don't know
hold on i might have gotten my lines
confused here might have gotten my lines
confused
uh let's check let's check yeah king d4
king b6 takes takes
and i believe this end game is also
winning
uh because again okay yeah this is this
is pretty clear again we're coming in
with rook f4 and we're getting a very
very similar end game here where black
is going to be able to get connected
past pawns and win
for example rook b3 again g4
and again connected past pawns and again
it's it's winning
so
uh
if you don't believe me look for
yourself uh i analyzed this for quite a
while and i think rookie just wins but
anyways rook a7 x-clam uh puts white
into ziggs bomb so we see rook c3 check
now king takes on d4 and a4 again with
the same idea we want to activate our
rook and uh
we'll activate our basically activate
our pawn use our pawn as a decoy so we
can have enough counter play to draw the
game we get rook a7 or k3
and then again
blacks to move here see if you can come
up with another important resource
another important move
maybe
it's one of the pieces that's
left yeah
um
so that's definitely we can go king c4
or something is what you're thinking
about i guess
yeah so king c4 is one idea but i think
again
we're just going to be pushing this guy
and
it's a lot of calculating to do but
again i think white is just close enough
to the king's side here your king's a
little bit too boxed out for you to be
able to to go for this
okay brian counted all the legal moves
in the position let's see if he's right
that's one two three four five six seven
eight nine 10 11 12 13 14. 15 legal
moves
all right the math checks out
yeah
the math checks out
yeah that's exactly right um this is
probably a similar feeling to when we
looked at rook a8 uh again rook a8 was
the correct in the one of the initial
positions i showed because we could go
rook a4 stopping the a pawn on his
tracks
so that white can't get that active play
and the idea is the same here we want to
go rook a5 stop this pawn on a4 before
it becomes a problem for us before we
need to divert all of our pieces back
and end up in those end games that uh
that aren't winning for black so rook a5
is a great start
uh we get rook back to a1 now let me
just check where we are
okay uh so now
black has obviously made quite a bit of
progress since uh since we started that
progress comes in the form of having an
extra d-pawn so it's pretty intuitive
what's black's idea
uh to follow
yeah
push the pawn forward
so that's what rubenstein does he goes
king c4
uh king to e3 and d4 check
okay king back to d2
and now it's it's getting a little bit
tougher to make more progress with uh
with the d-pawn
so again we have to find uh
find some way to remaneuver our pieces
and one more time let me make sure
critical idea is here okay we are at the
critical moment
so again
now we are getting almost an exact
repetition of the ideas that i was
talking about uh when whites allowed a
d-pawn on the board all those principles
are coming into play again
so if you
so sorry go ahead
oh yeah i i can't really see it's tough
uh
yeah so if you remember uh when we first
started in this end game we played rook
a8 and then rook a4
and then eventually we came through with
this critical idea king c4 and king c4
was so important because it freed up our
rook we used our king to blockade the a
pawn to use our rook to make threats on
the other side of the board because the
rook's more powerful it's a more
powerful piece than the king it's better
at attacking pawns than the king
so the same goes for this position we
want to do this changing of the guard
again you know we used our rook to stop
the pawn immediately and now we want to
use our king instead to help stop the
pawn
so it's just a question of what's the
most accurate way to do that
is the the critical point to stop the
pawn but uh it turns out most accurate
is to go rook f5 first we gain a tempo
on this guy so you don't have time to
push
then after king e1 now king b4
and this is the the point for black
we're using our king to stop the a pawn
to free up our rook to to make threats
on the other side of the board
uh and from here if i'm not mistaken i
think uh
white is just close to busted so king e2
and what's the continuation of our idea
now
yeah just king a5 uh we
transpose the rook and the king put the
king in front of the pawn
uh to free up our rook to make threats
now rook to
a3
and again our our job is not so simple
uh our job is not so simple so
uh again we just want to improve our
rook now to make more threats so as
we're
kind of cutting it close on time here
i'll just show some moves so rook f4
rook a2 rook h4 we bring her up to h4
defends our d pawn pressures the the
important uh the important h pawn
now here white just goes king d3 and i
think this is a pretty critical mistake
because it allows black to take on h3
and we're gonna end up in this end game
here which is
once again going to be busted for white
the the three versus one here
is not so easy to draw um and we'll get
into that in a moment but of course what
do you think would be a better way
for
uh black to try to hold on here
i'm white white to hold on
you can try rook a3
but what's the problem with this move
yeah the king attacks the rook
so we need to move this guy where do you
want to move him to
um
well no no i mean this is i think the
best idea for white at this point
okay d3 but now i can take your pawn and
then my king is free to join join the
party so i think instead
white should head back to a1
give up the h pawn but now of course our
big improvement is that the king is no
longer out in front of uh of the pawn
and we have ideas like this once again
we have to block hate it and then while
your king comes over here
uh i should be able
to uh to come in with my king
and i think actually this end game might
also be losing but i
think that this is the best that that
white could go for um at this moment i
think that the damage is sort of already
done here
so that's why white goes king d3 instead
but this end game is also not so good
just to show the technique uh spielman
now goes with rookie two rook f4 is very
very active again black's goal here is
to just just get those two connected
past pawns so king f or king e3 we bring
the king back into play
white tries to cut the king off
but now um after rook a4
i think the idea here was just to
uh bring the king in with rook a6 to c6
so white tries to go after the pawns on
the king side instead allowing the king
back
in but
g6 is uh the critical move here
if white does not go for this blockade
we're just gonna go king e6 and win the
game
uh check
king f5 for example or check g6 king f5
for example black keeps all the pawns
can play g4 and get that winning
position just to
show it's kind of hard to even play
moves here but yeah let's say something
like this
g6 um we want to stop the checks
and this should be
uh
pretty easy for for black to win uh
we're gonna go with g4
and win the game
so instead king f5 this allows g6
and this pawn end game is winning after
g4 you can come over here
uh but
again let me make sure i'm not messing
anything up i think just king f4
and
uh you have too many problems here
too many problems
and so rubenstein is winning the game
so now the question becomes well where
did white go so wrong and i think that
that happens
back here somewhere so
um
yeah i think this move king d2 is is the
big mistake here for
whites and i'm not going to try to solve
it um
right here but i thought that king e4
might be a better try no i'm wrong so
king d2 was correct rook f5 king e1
um but here
yes here i think uh white needs to try
to get active once again we need to come
out with our rook and get active a
little bit earlier uh which is why uh
black ended up losing after a k3 because
this rook h4 idea is is just too strong
it's just too strong
um
and the engine again says that this is
actually the best idea for whites
my impression was that this end game
should be losing anyways
and yeah my impression was correct so
here
um rook c1 and white could have tried to
get active earlier on and that would be
the way to save the game which is why
all those moves ago rook a7 big mistake
big mistake um
and chess authors of of history are are
in
are in shambles
uh also back here uh here rook c1 a
little bit earlier is also good enough i
think
can come in and get active with the rook
and so this is the problem uh for black
this is why black is not just directly
winning
um okay so let's review and then i'll
open it up to some questions
so we started in this position and we
said black should be better because
white has all these pawn islands uh rook
takes c2 as necessary otherwise white's
going to get very active with something
like d7 so we trade the rooks and then
we immediately go with rook a8 and this
move is better than the alternative rook
b3 or king e7 because we need to stop
white's a pawn on a3 we don't want to
let this pawn advance after something
like rook a2 and the pawn goes forward
so we use our rook to blockade the pawn
now what happens next of course we bring
the king in and then our big improving
idea
first we fix the structure on the king's
side make it super solid
then we bring our king into c4
why is bringing the king into c4 so
important because we want to stop the a
pawn with our king to free up our rook
so we change out the rook for the king
uh as far as guarding the pawn goes
stopping the pawn from advancing
this allows us to make threats in the
center of the board and on the king side
using the rook threats like rookie four
so white then has to give up the d pawn
in exchange for the d pawn white gets to
push the pawn one more square so again
now we get a repetition of the ideas we
use our rook to stop the pawn what's
next we swap out uh the rook for the
king we play rook f5 and bring our king
to a5 to stop the pawn
and then uh finally we see white
buckling under the pressure with this
rook coming through and winning on the
king's slide and as they say the rest is
technique um
easier said than done sometimes
but this position is winning with the
active rook on f4 and the king coming
back
to the center of the board
so couple really important end games
like endgame ideas here uh i can't
stress enough uh how important this move
rook a8 is in this position this is
really the only practical try otherwise
rook a2 and the pawn starts getting
pushed and every square that pawn gets
becomes a bigger and bigger problem for
black
so really nice repetition of ideas like
hitting with the rook switching the
workout for the king and then doing it
all over again in order to win the game
uh so any questions on this end game i
know we just spent an hour on the one
end game but uh it was kind of worth it
i think there was a lot going on here
so any questions for me
julian
um in your line with king d2
uh
what
what was black doing against rookie iii
i have no idea what you're talking about
line with king d2 before this so um
sorry you said it was room key eight
right yeah
rookie and you said white should play
candy too here right yeah but i was
thinking
ah no big mistake big mistake we
analyzed this end game
yeah
you can't play a4 because then i just
take it and if you come back this way
again if you play a4
i can now take your d pawn
um okay and yeah g5 i guess might be
somewhat important here so you don't
have to calculate anything
but uh if you're any slower
then my pawns just defend themselves
with something like this we saw a
different version where black was able
to do this
but yeah rookie 3 you just take it and
the king and pawn end game is winning in
this line as well
okay any other questions
okay great wolf in the chat says when
black plays rick f5 could white just
give the f pawn for a5 same as one of
those later lines so i think you're
talking about
uh this position can you just play a5
and yeah the difference here is that you
are getting your pawn to be super far
advanced i'm just in time to stop it
but the difference here is that i have
three pawns on the other side of the
board rather than
similar positions without this this e
pawn or d-pawn on the board the d-pawn
makes a big difference
because here i don't necessarily have to
come back with my king i can just start
pushing my other pawns as well for
example
how do i want to do this let's say i
play king d5
and check for example i'm gonna give up
this pawn just come take this guy and i
can push on this side of the board
uh good question though good question
okay anything else before we call
tonight
all rights
so with that the rook endgame god akiba
rubenstein wins
against spielman and we didn't even get
to look at the other end game i wanted
to go over but that's okay
so as always i want to thank you guys so
much for joining me here on youtube and
in person
um next week this class will be taught
by grand master alex yermalinsky he's
coming in as our next grand master in
residence so don't miss that one i'm
super excited to have uncle yermo here
with us i think it's going to be a lot
of good chess content
so as always my name is caleb denby
thank you very much for watching and i
will see you next time
[Music]
you